تحذيرا دوليا مطلق من دواء بسيط لكنه
منتشر على نطاق واسع شراب السعال هو ياتي
هذا التحذير بعد حاله وفاه مشبوها لاكثر
من 300 طفل معظمهم دون سن الخامسه في ثلاث
دول الوفيات مرتبطه بادويه تحتوي مستويات
عاليه من مواد سامه اعتبرتها المنظمه وقد
تكون قاتله حتى مع تناول جرعات قليله منها
ولا يجوز استعمالها في العلاجات الاطفال
المتضررون من دول غامبيا واندونيسيا
واوزباكستان لكن منظمه الصحه تعتقد ان
الادويه قد تكون متاحه في دول اخرى عديده
مثل الفلبين والسنغال وكامبوتيا ولمنع
الشعر الازمه تدعوا المنظمه لسحب الادويه
التي تنتجها الشركات الهنديه واندونيسيه
فورا من الاسواق طبعا سنبحث ما اذا كان
هناك داعا حقيقي للقلق لكن اولا المزيد
حول سوق ادويه السعال العالمي معك علاء
بلغت قيمه سوق ادويه السعال العالميه خمسه
ملايين ومئت 232 مليون دولار في عام 2019
ومن المتوقع ان تتجاوز السته ملايين دولار
بحلول عام 2027 نمو السوق العالميه لادويه
السعال يرتبط بارتفاع الاصابه باضطرابات
الجهاز التنفسي بالاضافه الى الزياده في
اعداد المسنين والتلوث حول العالم لا تنصح
اداره الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه اف دي ايه
بادويه السعال التي تصرف بدون وصفه طبيه
للاطفال اقل من عامين لانها قد تسبب اثار
جانبيه خطيره خاصه اذا حصل الصغار على
جرعات زائده عن الحاجه عام 2007 نشرت
دراسه في دوريه امريكيه خلصت الى ان تناول
العسل للسعال الليلي عند الاطفال يعملوا
على قمع الاعراض بشكل افضل من ادويه
السعال اطباء اخرون حضروا من عدم غسل
الاسنان بعد تناول شراب السعال ما يمكن ان
يسبب التسوس حيث تعمل شركات لاضافه الكثير
من السكريات لجعل الشراب مستساغا
[موسيقى]
ينضم لنا في الفيديو الصيدلي احمد حازم
احمد اهلا بك يسعد صباحك الصحه اذا تحذر
من دواء للسعال يحتوي مواد سامه ادى الى
مقتل 300 طفل ما مدى خطوره ذلك هلاك ان
تشرح لنا اولا
ريبورت او التقرير اللي اصدر عن طريق نظام
الصحه العالميه فهو كان مختص بمنتجات
لشركه ادويه معينه ما كانش لكل ادويه
السعال
والواقعه دي حصلت في بعض الدول زي اا
بنجلاديشيا وهمم
في افريقيا فهي مش شامله كل ادويه السعال
يعني برده همم للتوضيح بالنسبه للموضوع ده
طيب احمد ليست المراه الاولى التي يتم
فيها التحذير من ادويه السعال حول العالم
لمنذ سنين ويتم التحذير وما زلنا نرى هذه
الادويه في الرفوف الاولى في الصيدليات
وحتى تعطى بدون وصفه طبيب الى متى هو بس
يمكن الموضوع السعال همم الناس المحتاجه
ان هي تكون فهماك كويس ان هو رد فعل طبيعي
للجسم ان هو بيقدر بيساعده همم ان يتخلص
من اي افرازات مضره بالرقه بس مع ذلك لان
الاهالي
والاداء او كده خايفين على اطفالهم من همم
الاعراض السعال بشكل عام بيبقى عايزين
حاجه تهدي فعلا بس بصفه عامه لما بنشوف
منظمه الصحه والدواء الامريكيه هي بتحذر
من استخدام همم ادويه السعال خصوصا بدون
وصفه طبيه للاطفال اللي عمرهم اقل من اربع
همم سنوات
اقل من اربع سنوات هل يجوز اعطاء دواء
سعال الاطفال دون الاربع سنوات اقل اربع
سنوات ده غير مصرح به من منظمه الصحه
والدواء الامريكيه ويمكن استخدام في بدائل
اخرى لتهدئه السعال بالنسبه همم مش عشبيه
بس في بدائل منها استخدام عسل النحل على
سبيل المثال بس بشرط ان يكون الطفل اكبر
من عمر اا سنه في برده من الحاجات اللي
بتستخدم في البيوت حاجه اسمها كول ميست
هيومي ديفاير والهيوم ديفاير اللي هو
بيطلع همم بخار ميه بيقلل من اعراض السعال
عند الطفل بدون استخدام اي همم ادويه
وبنستخدم النوع اللي هو الكونست مش الوورد
لان وور المسك ممكن يزود من اعراض
الاحتقان عن همم الاطفال يعني هناك اوقات
اصلا لترشيد استخدام الادويه بشكل عام
وتقليل استهلاكها من قبل المستهلكين هل
ممكن اليوم ان تقوم شركات الادويه بمنع
اجراء تداول هكذا نوع من ادويه ادويه سعال
وحتى بتعاون مع وزاره الصحه ان تصدر
قرارات صارمه
يعني مش هنقدر ان احنا نقول ان ده قرار
ممكن يحصل في الوقت الحالي استخدام ادويه
السعال المنتشره على مستوى العالم كله
بشكل مبالغ فيه يمكن المفروض يكون موجود
دلوقت هي توعيه الاهالي بشكل همم الخاص ان
هم ما يستخدموش الادويه دي بدون وصفه طبيه
همم خصوصا ان هي مجرد ان هي بتقلل اعراض
السعال لكن السعال في احد ذاته هو زي ما
قلنا هو عرض مفيد بالنسبه للطفل طالما ان
هو بعيد عن اعراض الحساسيه او الازمه ففي
الحاله دي بيبقى محتاج همم
احمد
على الادويه المعروفه السعال هناك
يعني هل هي يعني للاطفال همم الحقيقه برده
لو هنتكلم عن نظام الصحه والدواء
الامريكيه فهي علقت على الادويه العشبيه
اللي من النوع همم اللي تكلمت عنه وقالت
ان احيانا كثير بيكون همم تركيزات المواد
العشبيه فيها اكثر من المكتوب على الادويه
نفسها فطبعا لو هنستخدم مواد عشبيه تكون
دايركت يعني من غير ما تكون موجوده في شكل
همم دوائي فعشان كده نظام صحه والدواء
الامريكيه لا تنصح باستخدام برده المنتجات
دي مع الاطفال اا وهي معظمها او كما مصرح
به من نظام الصحه والدواء غير همم
نوت برود او غير مصرح به من منظمه
لاستخدمه مع الاطفال احنا نشكره جزيل
الشكر